we start with breaking news tonight one
person is dead after a fire broke out in
a Southeast Valley Home Madison
Kimbrough is live in the Silverado Ranch
neighborhood with the latest
as you can see police are still on scene
behind me this happening near Maryland
Parkway and Serene and in the Silverado
Ranch neighborhood like Vanessa like you
mentioned now Clark County Fire
Department reporting like you mentioned
that one person was found dead in the
home prior to that ccfd Crews responded
to the residents as well as two units
from Henderson Fire Department Crews
were unable to enter the residence when
they got to the scene and began what
they called quote defensive operations
once the bulk of the fire was out Crews
were able to enter and that's when they
found one person dead it's unclear where
in the house that person's body was
located according to fire officials
Flames were coming out of all of the
windows on the rear side of the house at
one point it's unknown at this time if
any neighboring homes surrounding the
residents were affected by the Flames
but as you can see it doesn't look like
it as the house seems to be a couple
doors down in the area but this has been
a very active scene all evening again
this started around 7 15 uh we haven't
really seen any neighbors out here yet
but this area here in the Silverado
Ranch neighborhood is blocked off
unknown when this tape will come up and
when police will leave but this fire is
still under investigation gonna send it
back to you